can you maybe explore the
possible alternatives
to uh the big bang theory so there are
many alternatives um starting with so
this the singularity quantum
cosmologically demanding singular
origin of the universe that stands in
contrast to these other models in which
time does not have a beginning
many of them feature cycles at least one
cycle possibly infinite number of cycles
called by sir roger penrose and they all
have things in common these alternatives
as does the dominant paradigm of
cosmogenesis which is inflation
inflation is sort of can be thought of
as this a spark that ignites the hot big
bang that i said we understood so it's
an earlier condition but it's still not
an initial condition in physics imagine
imagine i i show you a grandfather clock
or pendulum swinging back and forth you
look away for a second you know i come
into the room pendulum swinging back and
forth alex tell me where did it start
how how many cycles is going to make
before the er you can't answer that
question without knowing the initial
conditions in a very simple system like
a one dimensional simple harmonic
oscillator like a pendulum think about
understanding the whole universe without
understanding the initial conditions
it's a tremendous lacunae gap that we
have as scientists that we may not be
able to in the inflationary cosmology
determine the quantitative physical
properties of the universe prior to
what's called the inflationary epoch so
you're saying for the pendulum in that
epoch we can't because uh you can infer
things about the panel before you show
up to the room
in our current epic correct right yeah
so if you look at it right now but if i
said well when will it stop oscillating
so that depends on how much energy it
got initially and you can measure its
dissipation it's air resistance yeah
infrared camera you can see it's getting
hotter maybe and you could do some
calculations but to know the two things
in physics to solve a partial
differential equation are the initial
conditions and the boundary conditions
battery conditions were here on earth as
a gravitational field it's not going to
excurse or you know make excursions you
know wildly beyond the length of the
pendulum it's not um you know it has
simple properties um so but and this is
like in other words you can't tell me
you know when did the solar system start
orbiting in the way that it does now in
other words when did the moon acquire
the exact angular momentum that it has
now
um now that's a pretty pedestrian
example but what i'm telling you is that
the inflationary epoch purports and is
successful at providing a lot of
explanations for how the universe
evolved after inflation took place and
ended but it says nothing about how it
itself took place and that's really what
you're asking me i mean you don't really
look what you care about like big bad
nucleosynthesis and the elements got
made and these fusion reactors and and
the whole universe was a fusion reaction
but like don't you really care about
what happened at the beginning of time
at the first moment of time
and the problem is we can't really
answer that in the context of the big
bang we can't answer that in the context
of these alternatives so you asked me
about some of the alternatives so one is
a on theory the conformal cyclic
cosmology of siraja penrose another one
that's that's um it was was really
popular in the 60s and 70s until the
discovery of the primary component of my
research field the cosmic microwave
background radiation or cmb the three
kelvin all-pervasive signal that
astronomers detected in 1965. that kind
of spelled the death knell in some sense
to the what was called the
quasi-steady-state universe
and
and then there was another um
uh model that kind of came out of that
you hear the word quasi so it's not
steady state steady state means always
existed that was a cosmology einstein
believed until hubble showed him
evidence for the expansion of the
universe
and most scientists believed in that for
you know millennia basically the
universe was eternal static unchanging
um they couldn't believe that after
hubble so they had to append onto it
concatenate this uh this new feature
that it wasn't steady it was
quasi-steady so the universe was making
a certain amount of hydrogen every
century in a given volume of space and
that amount of hydrogen that was
produced was constant but because it was
producing more and more every century
the centuries pile up and the volume
piles up the universe could expand and
so that's how they develop slowly very
slowly and it doesn't match
observational evidence so that but that
is a an alternative by the way did i say
i think the the the steady state
universe is infinite or finite do you
know um
he i i would assume that he thought it
was infinite because there was really
you know if something had a no beginning
in time then it would be very unlikely
we're in like the center of it or it's
bounded or it has in that case a finite
edge to it i wonder what he thought
about infinity because that's such an
uncomfortable nice silly joke i'm sure
you're familiar with this silly joke
right
a silly joke was that um there are only
two things that are infinite um the
universe and human stupidity and i'm not
sure about the universe so well me
saying i'm not aware of the joke is a
good example of the joke it's very meta
okay so uh all right so sorry you were
saying about quasi
all the alternatives in the quasi-steady
state and the most kind of promising
although i hate to say that you know
people say like what's your favorite you
know alternative right this is not
investment advice
inflation is not transitory it is
quasi-permanent um so a very prominent
sorry to interrupt we're talking about
cosmic inflation so calm down
cryptocurrency folks that's right
although the first nobel prize
uh and one of the first nobel prizes in
economics was awarded for inflation not
of the cosmological kind uh so most
people don't know inflation has already
won a nobel prize it's a good topic to
work on if you want a nobel prize
doesn't matter the field exactly it's
time translation invariant so when we
look at um the alternative that's called
the bouncing or cyclic cosmologies these
have serious virtues um according to
some
one of the virtues to me just as a human
i'm just speaking uh you know as a human
um one of the founders of the new
version of the um of the cyclic
cosmology called uh called the bouncing
cosmology is paul steinhardt he's the
einstein professor of natural sciences
at princeton university you may have
heard of it
and he was one of the originators of
what was called new inflation
in other words he was one of the
founding fathers of inflation
who now not only has no belief or
support for inflation he actively claims
that inflation
is baroque pernicious dangerous
malevolent not to science not just to
cosmology but to society so here's a man
who created a theory that's captivated
the world or universe of cosmologists
such as it is not a huge universe but
they're more podcasters than
cosmologists uh some do both but uh but
this this man created this this theory
with collaborators
and now he's like i joke i'm like paul
you're denying paternity like you're
like a deadbeat dad now you're saying
like inflation's is is bogus oh and but
he doesn't just attack see this is
what's very important about
approaching things as an experimentalist
you got a lot of theorists on and that's
wonderful and i think that's a huge
service an experimentalist has to say no
he or she has to be confident to say
like i don't care if i prove you right
or i prove your enemy wrong or whatever
we have to be like exterminators and
nobody likes the exterminator until they
need one right or the garbage collectors
right but it's vital that we be
completely
kind of unpersuaded by the beauty and
the magnificence and the symmetry and
the simplicity of some idea like
inflation is a beautiful idea
but it also has consequences and what
paul claims i don't agree with him fully
on this point is that those consequences
are dangerous because they lead to
things like the multiverse which is
outside the purview of science and in
that sense i can
see support for what he does but none of
that detracts from my respect for a man
um you know imagine like you know elon
comes up with this like really great
idea you know space and he's like
actually it's not it's not gonna work
and you know but like here's this better
idea and he's like spacex is not gonna
work but he's now creating an
alternative to it it's it's extremely
hard to do what paul has done it doesn't
mean he's right doesn't mean i'm gonna
like have more and more attention paid
to it because he's my friend or because
i respect the idea or i respect the man
um and his colleague anna aegis who
works really hard with him
but nevertheless this has certain
attractions to it and what um what it
does most foremost is that it removes
the quantum gravity aspect from
cosmology
so it takes away
50 of the motivation for a theory of
quantum gravity
you you talked a lot about quantum
gravity uh you talk people eminent
people on the show always latent in
those conversations is sort of the
teleological expectation that there is a
theory of everything there is a theory
of quantum gravity but there's there's
no law that says we have to have a
theory of quantum gravity
so that that kind of uh implicit
expectation has to do ultimately with
the inflationary theory so in cosmic
inflation so is that at the core so okay
uh maybe you can speak to what is uh the
negative impacts on society
from
uh believing in in cosmic inflation so
you know one of the more kind of robust
predictions of inflation according to
its other two patriarchs you know
considered to be his patriarchs alan
guth at mit and andre linde at stanford
although he was in the ussr when he came
up with these ideas um uh along with
paul steinhardt was that the universe
has to eventually get into a quantum
state
it has to exist in this hilbert space
and the helper space has certain
features and those features are quantum
mechanical endowed with quantum
mechanical properties
and then it becomes very difficult to
turn inflation off
so inflation can get started but then
it's it's like one of you know spacex
rockets it's hard to turn off a solid
rocket booster right it continues the
thrusting energy you need another
mechanism to douse the flames of the
inflationary expansion which means that
if inflation kicks off somewhere it will
kick off potentially everywhere at all
times including now spawning an ever
increasing
set of universes some will die stillborn
some will continue and flourish and this
is known as the multiverse paradigm
it's a robust seemingly robust
consequence not only of inflationary
cosmology but more and more we're seeing
it in string theory as well so that you
know sometimes two you know branches
coming to the same conclusion as is you
know taken as evidence for its reality
so one of the negative consequences is
it creates
phenomena that we can't uh that are
outside the reach of experimental
science yeah or is it that the
multiverse somehow has a philosophical
negative effect on humanity like it
makes us um
maybe makes life seem more meaningless
is that is that is that where he's
getting at a little bit or is it not
reaching that far well no i think those
are both kind of perceptive
the answer is a little both because in
one sense it's meant
kind of to explain this fine-tuning
problem that we find ourselves in a
universe that's particularly fasan that
has features can come you know
consistent with our existence and how
could we be otherwise you know the sort
of weak anthropic principle um on the
other hand it a theory that predicts
everything literally everything um can
be said to predict nothing like if i say
lexi you know you've been working out
you you look like you know yeah you
haven't yeah it's great uh you look like
you're you know about somewhere under 10
000 kilograms you're like all right yeah
you're right but that's horribly
imprecise so what good is that that's
meaningless i don't contribute any
what's called surprise or reduction in
entropy
or
you know reduction of your ignorance
about the system you know exactly how
much you weigh um so me telling you that
tells you nothing in this case it's
basically saying that we're living in a
universe because the overwhelming odds
of our existence um dictate that we
would exist there has to be at least one
place that we exist but the problem is
um it's a manifestation of infinity so
humans and and i'm sure you know this
from your work with ai and ml and
everything else
that humans as far as we know really are
the only entities capable of
contemplating infinity but we do so very
imperfectly right so if i say to you
like what's bigger the number of you
know water molecules and and this thing
or the number of real numbers or if i
say what's bigger the number real
numbers are rational numbers they're all
different classifications of the amount
of infinities that there could be
infinity to the infinity power you know
when you have kids someday they'll tell
you i love you infinity you have to come
back i love you infinity plus one right
so uh but the human brain can't really
contemplate infinity let me illustrate
that
they say in the singularity the universe
had an infinite temperature right so
let me ask you a question is there
anything that you can contemplate in the
observe you know einstein's little clip
aside that's infinite like a physical
property density pressure temperature
energy that's infinite
and if you can think of such thing i'd
like to know it but if you can how does
it go to infinity minus one you know the
opposite direction i go with my kids
how does it go from like the half of
infinity because that's still infinity
how did it cool down how did it get more
and more tenuous and rarified so now
it's only infinity over two in terms of
less infinite more infinite
yeah i mean it's uh that's one of the
biggest
troubling things to me about infinity is
uh you can't truly hold it inside our
minds it's a mathematical construct that
doesn't it feels like intuition fails
and but nevertheless we use it
nonchalantly and then
use like physicists they're incredible
intuition machines and then they'll play
with this infinity as if
they can play with it on the level of
intuition as opposed to the level of
math
you know yeah maybe something cyclical
you can imagine infinity just going
around the same
um kind of like a mobius strip situation
but then uh the question then arises how
do you make it more or less infinite uh
yeah all of that intuition fails
completely and i mean how do you
represent it in a computer right it's
either some placeholder for infinity or
it's one divided by a very the smallest
you know possible um you know real
number that you can represent in the
memory well that's basically my
undergraduate study in computer science
is how to represent a floating point in
a computer i think i took 17 courses on
this topic it was very useful i came to
the right place but um but you know in
terms of what a physicist will mean
you're right i mean physicists will
blindly nonchalantly subtract infinity
you know renormalization and do things
to get finite answers and it's it's it's
miraculous but you know at a certain
point you have to ask well where what
are the consequences for the real world
so one of them you ask you know what
what's the problem does it make us more
meaningless they proport many of the
people that support it like andre linde
in fact andre linde says you have a bias
for you lex me brian you have a bias
that you believe in a universe
but shouldn't you believe in a in a
multiverse what what evidence do you
have that there's not a mo so he turns
it around whereas paul steinhardt will
say no if anything can happen then
there's no predictive power within the
theory because you can always say well
this value of the inflationary field did
not predict produce sufficient uh
gravitational wave energy for us to
detect it with bicep or simon's
observatory or whatever but that doesn't
mean that inflation didn't happen and
that's logically a hundred percent
correct but it's like it's like kind of
chewing you know wonder wonder bread you
know uh i apologize if they're one of
your sponsors but you know
wonder breads
you